pour pouvoir les enfants bonsoir petit
louis et mirabel ont l'air très sage ce
soir j'espère que collombat a bien mangé
ces graines
et vous votre soupe et toi gros morceau
mois patron je mange toujours bien basse
ou c'est très bien ça nours une europe
je descends voir mes petits amis peu
pompeux propos par colomba soit sage
monge encore un peu de salade toutes
petites feuilles mademoiselle collombat
bonjour jamais l'os ne manges tu viens
faire le monde avec nous bien sûr les
enfants chicane et j'ai du pam à vendre
des rouges des blanches
j'en ai tant dans mon panier qu'elle
roule dans l'escalier trois ou quatre
pour un sou mademoiselle retournez vous
vous aussi mes petits amis chanter avec
nous 1 2 3 j'ai des pommes à vendre ses
débuts aux gens le temps dans mon panier
de leur rôle dans l'escalier trois ou
quatre pour ans aux madmoizelles retour
au bout j'étais pas mal à vendre des
rouges et des blanches
j'en ai éteint dans mon panier qu'elle
roule dans l'escalier trois ou quatre
pour un sou mamzelle dossier avec nous
je dépends bas ventre et budget des
ménages
je n'ai temps dans mon panier qu'elle
roule dans l'escalier trois ou quatre
pour un sou non elle dormait avec nous
je ne peux pas les enfants ulysse
m'attend
et ouais patron la rive vous voyez il me
surveille frein car je vous le promets
des enfants mais une autre fois la jette
à la lumière en dormez-vous vite
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants l'ennemi qui lui ni
merabet
[Musique]
venus est petit louis bonne nuit petite
mirabelle
bonne nuit à tous les enfants allez vite
vous coucher et faites de beaux rêves
nous reviendrons vous voir demain si
vous êtes bien sage en route une ourse
bonne nuit à demain à demain
[Musique]
e